[Música]
hola
buenas tardes este
no sé si les ha pasado de repente
después de un montón de años uno se topa
o algún compañero de kinder en la
sección de carnes del más por menos
y es esa gente que no cambió nada es
igualito sólo que más grande
de esa gente que siempre dijo voy a ser
médico y uno le pregunté que sé si soy
médico
tal vez porque mi vida todo salió tan
diferente a lo que yo imaginaba es un
poco me sorprende la gente que dijo que
iba a ser tal cosa y es desde los 5 o 6
años
y yo hago canciones mi vida ha salido
bastante diferente a lo que yo imaginaba
pero también me gusta lo que ha salido y
parte de eso es tramitar mis rollos y
mis preguntas y mis sentimientos a
través de las canciones y esta primera
tiene que ver con esos pedazos de vida
donde vos sentís una pared
y nada es lo que parecía y no hay como
traspasar la que todos nos ha pasado en
algunos momentos y podés resignarse
poderes echarte a morir o poder sentirla
sentirla a tientas y oscuras
[Música]
a
si no se comparte para despertar
[Música]
discúlpame lata solo yo insistía en
esperar un código completo una meta
total y un dios en blanco y negro
[Música]
todo se mete antes de caminar
ah
[Música]
después de ver con mi construir tan
pocas certidumbres
santa sede ahora sin las puntas de mis
dedos como un compás
y hay tanta transparente que hay tantas
que se sienten en la oscuridad
[Música]
lenguajes dialecto siento pero con la
paz
la piedra tantos bordes ásperos por
recorrer
sí
t
es un poco tarde pero estoy aquí estoy
en braille
y campo lo que puede ser distinto al día
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
si acaso hay un relámpago un instante
nítido de claridad
no
le tengo miedo a la oscuridad
el mensaje abierto que vuelvo
pero no improvisa yo soy un poco tarde
pero estoy aquí
con todos mis sentidos
no habría leído
no tendré que
pero desierto al cielo
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
a mí me dio por escribir bueno me ha
dado por escribir desde chiquitilla pero
hasta ahora me ha dado por publicar que
da un poco de miedo
y quiero compartir con ustedes un
pedacito de este libro porque son como
cuentos cortos o cosas que siento
también un poco de poesía esto se llama
like
nunca es tarde yo sabe lo que hace todo
es para algo si amas a alguien déjalo ir
cada frase con su música dulce heroica o
esperanzadora según sea el caso la
imagen podría ser un peluche con
corazones un pájaro en un alambre o una
silueta solitaria en un risco al
amanecer cada quien defiende a sus
pasiones con likes y dedos pulgares
sintiéndose parte de algo más grande que
alivió ser parte de un grupo de otros
tan semejantes tomas partido por temas
de cualquier índole la clonación del
último rinoceronte blanco el aborto los
diputados la pugna desigual entre uber y
los taxistas rojos entre la pequeña
empresa y las transnacionales uno se
identifica con star wars otros con
cristo otros con el yoga de la ayahuasca
los enemas purificadores la palabra
amistad cambio de significado tener más
es más importante que tener de adeveras
las amistades padecen de prisa porque
hay demasiadas que atender
el tiempo no alcanza para hablar con
todo y de vacaciones anécdotas olores y
gestos ese lujo de verse a los ojos
tendrán que alcanzar los mensajes de
texto
la respuesta se simplifica se hace
posible ahorrar palabras y opinar con
cáritas me gusta me entristece me enoja
me divierte lo amo no hay una noche y
todavía para me vale
la respuesta tiene que caber en muy
pocas caracteres no se complique no
divaga no se extienda el blanco y negro
está de moda lo nuevo lo último lo más
reciente la exigencia vertiginosa
consiste en actualizar y actualizarse
permanentemente te sonríen con cierta
lástima mal disimulada si no usas
instagram o si todavía todavía
colecciona discos compactos si escoges
envejecer sin botox por efectúen y one
y ahora si tienes miles de seguidores y
buscas más tan social y tan sociable que
olvidas cómo era conversar sin
interrupciones cómo era sentarse a una
mesa con café y sin teléfonos cómo era
una reunión sin tener que tomar una sola
foto para validarla
botas contra la hambruna en áfrica y
contra luisito rey botas a favor de los
derechos humanos del rescate animal de
la sele y en contra de los malvados
países sin papel higiénico te acostás
con el alivio y el orgullo de hablar de
haber dado tu opinión de haber aportado
a la causa de haber conseguido 50 likes
por el maquillaje el ángulo de la foto y
el escote
aprendiste de paso que el jengibre es
más bueno de lo que imaginaste que más
refugiados se ahogaron que 14 estrellas
de hollywood envejecieron muy feo
que más líderes desquiciados llegaron al
poder más corrupción se está exponiendo
y más te urge refugiarse en las series
de netflix que están buenísimas
la amistad es un número
la opinión es un icono
la libertad es una estatua todo importa
nada importa y lo lograron la dispersión
en la regla la liviandad es lo posible
la soledad es apagar
[Aplausos]
y
cuando el ocaso suceda que pierdan filo
cuando tocarte no te vuelva el reloj
cuando la prisa pierda a cabo de mi mesa
cuando un ocupe recoger lo que callo
cuando mi paz no sea un capricho de la
luna cuando encuentra libia nada en el
de todo y la paciencia sea más que esa
palabra
que suele usarse por decir resignación
cuando el dolor se vuelva
solo una señal para moverse y un lugar
donde vivir voy a poder ponerme el
vestido de flores sembrar viejos amores
y aceptar lo que perdí
podía ponerme vestido de flores
clausurar diego rencores y partir de
aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando no espere más milagros que los
míos más pierda vigencia cualquier dios
condenación cuando entre teclas halla
más que dos colores y si no me importe
si entendés esta canción
[Música]
lo fascinó parezca sospechoso y lo
difícil ya no sea una virtud cuando la
música tolere mi silencio respirar
gritaré a su salud cuando el dolor se
vuelva sólo para sellar para moverse y
un lugar donde vivir
[Música]
pueden ponerme el vestido de flores
celebrar viejos sabores y ya sepa lo que
verte
el vestido de flores a clausurar diego
rencores y
a partir de aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]